The news is changing so rapidly every day
it's hard to keep up.
At the moment,
as COVID cases taper off
in countries like France and
Italy, they're going down,
the number of cases in the United States
continues to spike, sadly.
And that's why the European
Union recently announced
Americans are not allowed to travel there
until further notice.
We can't go to Europe. We're banned.
It's a very extreme measure.
I understand it, but it's extreme.
And this new tourism ad
for the European Union...
I don't know. I didn't
really appreciate it.
Take a look.
[Narrator] The European Union
is open for tourism again.
Come see it all, from the snow-capped Alps
to the verdant hills of Umbria.
There's so much to see in the E.U.
But even better, here's something
you won't see right now:
Americans!
Because of massive COVID
outbreaks in the U.S.,
Americans are banned from traveling here,
which means you'll get
to experience Europe
without experiencing American tourists
complaining about our very
reasonable portion sizes.
No Americans making fun
of David's perfectly averaged-sized penis.
You won't see American idiots doing this.
Or this.
No Americans demanding their
steak tartare cooked well done.
Or pointing and laughing
at our immodest swimwear.
So relax and enjoy America-free Europe!
Filled with busy cafes
and empty McDonald's.
Visit the E.U. now.
Quick! Before they find a vaccine.